من اهم مكونات الهيمنه الثقافيه والقوه
الناعمه للولايات المتحده بلا شك هي
هوليود التي تتحكم في قائمه اكثر الافلام
تحقيقا للايرادات وتوفر اكثر من مليونين
وظيفه في نيوزيلندا اجريت دراسته
استقصائيه حكوميه عام 2004 بعد اصدار
الجزء الثالث والاخير من ذا لورد اوف ذا
رينجز ووجدت ان 6% من الزوار اختاروا
نيوزيلندا كوجاتهم السياحيه اعتمادا على
السلسله
النيجيريه تضخ اكثر من 600 مليون دولار
سنويا في الاقتصاد بل وحلت محل الافلام
الامريكيه في كثير من الدول الافريقيه
بخلاف دورها في تغيير الصوره النمطيه
السلبيه عن مواطن نيجيريا مثال اخر على
تاثير السينمات قوه ناعمه فبعد اصدار فيلم
روما على منصه نتفليكس والذي فاز بافضل
فيلم اجنبي عام 2019 اصبح حي روما الذي
صورت فيه مشاهد الفيلم في المكسيك وجهه
سياحيه عصريه يجذب الاف السياح سنويا
واخيرا فيلم باراسايد اول فيلم غير ناطق
بالانجليزيه يحقق جائزه افضل فيلم في
هوليود قفز بصناعه السينما الكوريه الى
السماء وهو ما ترجمه نجاح مسلسل لعبه
الحبار الذي اصبح اكثر الاعمال مشاهده على
منصه